[Musique]
1965 noctambules se pressent à pigalle
le quartier chaud de paris pourquoi car
une nouvelle discothèque vient d'ouvrir
le bus palladium qui organise aussi des
concerts
on entend un vacarme formidable et je
crois que ça vient d'eux du palladium là
le lieu tire son nom d'une célèbre boîte
new yorkaise le palladium à l'origine un
homme d'affaires james h il se
présentait en 1966 chez votre vrai nom
oui c'est mon vrai nom c'est mon vrai
prénom je suis français j'ai 23 ans je
nomme idée à l'époque créé un réseau de
bus à destination des jeunes de banlieue
pour venir danser sur paris
d'où le mot bus dans bus palladium car
dans les années 60 les transports sont
quasi inexistants dans la région je suis
un homme d'affaires un aventurier g
j'aime le goût du risque
et quand on fait les effets il faut la
voir aussi grâce à son sens du business
james heard fait connaître le club dans
la capitale on y danse surtout le rock
mais en 1965 ils sont des milliers à
venir découvrir une nouvelle danse venue
des états unis le monde this
[Musique]
et
le bus palladium c'est la boîte branchée
où il faut aller tout le monde s'y
pressent les jeunes danse jusqu'au petit
matin d'autres s'endorme sur les
banquettes et les groupes s'époumone sur
scène
la discothèque je suis aussi les
nouvelles tendances musicales de grands
noms de la chanson et on fait des
concerts
1977 ambiance disco écoutez gloria
gaynor chanter never can say goodbye
[Musique]
vous préférez les tubes des années 80
alors direction 1983 avec le groupe
chagrin d'amour sur scène le duo
interprète quelques notes du tube chacun
fait ce qu'il lui plaît
le bus palladium c'est avant tout le
rock patti smith gloria gaynor joe
cocker on n'y a décerné le bus d'acier
sorte de trophée du rock à la française
en 2013 le groupe téléphone vient se
produire au bus palladium un concert
d'une heure totalement improvisée jean
louis aubert chante avant du maine à ses
côtés louis bertignac et à la batterie
richard kolinka trois des quatre membres
de téléphone il ne manque que la
bassiste à la place de corinne
marienneau le chanteur axel bauer mais
tout ça c'est terminé après 57 ans
d'existence le bus palladium ferme
définitivement ses portes le club
mythique va être rasée à la place un
autel sera construit
[Musique]